Let's talk about the Google trifecta, the three parts of Google and it's very important
that you guys understand this and guys the more that you can understand about Google
and how it works and how they think and how they operate, the easier it is for us to do
SEO because we just need to reverse engineer what they're thinking.
So really quick, the Google trifecta, that is the three different sections of Google.
First we have the ads, which is the very top section of Google.
So if you do a search, boom, you're going to see that at the top, it's going to say
ad next to it.
That's the ad section.
The next section that we're going to have is what we call Google Local.
It's also called the Google My Business or GMB or Google Business Profiles, whatever.
They keep changing the name.
It's also called the Map Pack, the Three Pack, whatever.
It's probably going to be called the Dinosaur Pack by the time this video.
I don't even know.
Whatever Google decides.
Larry Page and Sergey Brin, shout out to you guys for having some creative minds.
I don't know.
That's the local section.
And there is a specific strategy to ranking in that section that we are going to be covering
in a later module.
And then underneath the map, we have the third section, which is what we would call to or
I'm going to refer to as the actual organic listings, which is underneath the maps.
That's where your website ranks at the top of the organic.
So there's, depending on the search, there's usually one to three ads.
Then there's three in the map.
Sometimes there's four because there's an ad in the maps, if you look really careful.
One of those is an ad.
Then there's 10 search results.
And then sometimes you'll see some ads at the bottom.
And that is what makes up the Google Trifecta, ads, local, and organic.
Very important.
You understand that.
Let's keep going.